The internet has a lot of
thoughts about Keanu Reeves,
and so does Bridget Moynahan. So is the star
of "The Matrix" really as nice as he seems,
or are there some skeletons in his closet?
Moynahan's revelations may surprise you.
When you've worked in Hollywood for as long as
Keanu Reeves has, your reputation follows you
around everywhere. And in the case of movie
stars, the public gets to have an opinion
about an actor's on-the-job behavior even
if they don't have any direct experience
working with them. In the case of Reeves, his
general reputation seems to be that of a quiet,
humble, decent guy, who happens to be
one of the most famous people on Earth.
Of course, it helps when he partakes in
delightful interviews where he answers
questions like a normal person and has
viral stories come out of the woodwork
about what a down-to-earth person he is.
But is this reputation really accurate?
Every once in a while, someone who's worked with a
star like Reeves will give us a tidbit about what
the experience was like. Bridget Moynahan,
best known today as one of the stars of the
police drama "Blue Bloods," worked with Reeves
on both "John Wick" in 2014, and the sequel,
"John Wick: Chapter 2," in 2017. She played
his deceased wife, Helen Wick, whose final
act prior to her passing is gifting John a dog
so that he won't be as alone after she's gone.
As anyone who's seen the movies can attest,
that dog plays a pretty central role. And during
a 2014 interview, she wasn't shy to share her
impressions of what Reeves was like on the set.
Moynahan is no stranger to sharing the screen
with some of the biggest names in the business.
After all, she joins Tom Selleck and Donnie
Wahlberg on "Blue Bloods." With a resume that
also includes the likes of "Serendipity" and "Sex
and the City," it's safe to say Moynahan has been
around the block a few times and generally knows
what to expect when working with A-list stars.
During her interview with AOL, Moynahan was asked
about a bevy of her famous collaborators over the
years, including Al Pacino and, of course, Keanu
Reeves. When asked about how her experience of
working with Reeves on "John Wick" was, compared
to what she expected, Moynahan revealed,
"He's very quiet and very private. I had always
heard that about him, and he kind of still was."
"We had a really nice time. We were playing
a couple that was in love so
that was really fun to do."
It sounds like Moynahan didn't get a chance to
get to know Reeves too well, despite playing
the assassin's late wife in flashbacks. It makes
sense given her role is killed off pretty early
in the film, so she probably didn't spend too
much time getting to know the legendary actor.
But it also seems that her experience working
with Reeves was a positive one. He is,
after all, one of the co-stars that caused
Moynahan to declare during her interview,
"I have worked with the
best guys in the business."
When it comes to actors, one of the first things
people want to know is whether they're nice.
There are so many horror stories of celebrities
acting like divas and treating everyone they
perceive as beneath them like trash. Fortunately,
it doesn't appear as though Reeves falls in
this camp as several of his co-stars have
nothing but kind things to say about him.
First, there's his "John Wick 3" partner
Halle Berry, who took to Instagram
to gush over working with Reeves on the project.
Meanwhile, Lance Reddick, who's played Charon
in all three "John Wick" movies to date, had
nothing but nice things to say, either. The actor
described what a consummate professional Reeves
was on-set and even went so far as to declare,
"Whenever I work with a big movie star for
the first time, I keep my guard up to protect
my work from an ego. And if there's any big
movie star who's not that person, it's Keanu."
It appears that if you're going to star alongside
any A-list celebrity in a major motion
picture, you want it to be Keanu Reeves.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite celebrities are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.